i see you tearing up how close did you
come to die close
abby how are you doing there are days
that i wish
that i would have done
what is it like on the other side
there's so many women there
that should not be there oh my god
that's great
you know it's a good day when you can
bend over and get your pants on
i have to save my tears for the pillow
who's there for you
my doctors yes but uh
good friends loyal friends jojo and her
family have been wonderful
[Music]
abby great to see you but this has been
a crazy year how are you doing
i'm holding up it's been a lot of alone
time a lot of recovering
and uh i wish i could say a lot of
physical therapy but not really
how do you feel right now i feel okay my
back still gives me pain
my lower back around my tailbone is
painful
mostly because i'm sitting in the chair
so much i should be
up i should be walking i should have
physical therapy three four times a day
and with covet i don't but you're
walking i am walking
little baby steps and i should be
walking a lot i can do about 150 steps
before i have to take a rest and i don't
need to sit down i just need to stop and
rest it's mostly my arms
because i'm putting so much weight and
so much pressure into my arms to walk
that i don't trust my legs because i
can't feel the floor you still can't
feel the floor
where do you go from here up i think i'm
gonna stand up and walk for you
oh my god that's great am i there hold
on
i'll back up to it stop right there okay
you're right here
okay just back off yeah i'll feel it
it's like when i teach my girls how to
interview there's like a little
knob right here okay i got it you feel
the back of the
chair with your legs before you sit down
yeah okay yes
oh there you go who'd you bring with you
today this is dr malavan my hero
superman tell us first of all right off
the bat
how is abby doing in medical terms
i think abby has come a very long way
you know considering what she's gone
through with the
with the cancer that she had requiring
that emergency surgery
that should have never happened i mean
the surgery that she had recently that i
did on her
that should have been a surgery in and
out she should have been doing great
with that no problem
the problem was that the cancer surgery
because she never really had recovered
all the way
from that her body was deconditioned in
some ways but she needed this surgery
done too we actually were gonna do this
surgery
before like the cancer surgery because
we didn't know she had cancer at the
time like we were
thinking and then the surgery that i
just had was from an injury before
puberty yes that doctor found in
in my body that's why i went to him
because my hip was numb
it was going down my leg it was numb and
i went to see him
boom what was it so she had a
basically a stress fracture in the
vertebrae in the bottom which
you know some people get like about 10
of the population and it causes
the lowest vertebrae to start slipping
basically going forward and the plan was
that we were going to
operate on that area at all and there
was no there was no cancer around and
then
this was years ago right and then i went
on my staycation
and that thank you to the everyone's
taxes they paid for that
and and then i went to uh and then i
came out
and i i lost a bunch of weight i was in
the best shape i had ever been in
and you know since a kid and i was in a
halfway house in
hollywood and i got a pain in the back
of my neck and i went to six doctors
i went to the emergency room i was
admitted to the hospital for
72 hours didn't do an mri didn't find
anything
go home and take it easy honey you'll be
fine and then
it ended up being cancer
choking my spinal cord burkett lymphoma
and he did
eight hours of emergency surgery pulling
the slime it was like a black tar
they couldn't do the test because they
couldn't get me to stay still was i
remember was at midnight i said we were
going in
we don't have time and no mri going in
blind
been knocking me out they admitted me
and within 48 hours i was paralyzed from
the neck
down the cancer was it was unbelievable
how fast it had spread
over 12 segments did you think she was
going to die
you know i i always like to look at the
glass half full
than half empty i was like you know what
not on my watch it's not happening
i'm gonna do whatever it takes so i was
optimistic that we're gonna save her
that's how i always like to look at it i
see you tearing up how close did you
come to die
close i remember saying to the
uh anesthesiologist just tell me
i'm gonna see you when i wake up just
tell me i'm gonna see you when i wake up
and he said i can't tell you that man
that's what i knew and then i heard you
say something that
i didn't know he said get the theater
ready
i'm going in and i didn't know that the
operating room was called the theater
and i thought i died i already i'm dead
already and i can still hear them
talking this is weird
um but there are days that i wish
that i would have died why didn't you
why would you say that
would you i know i shouldn't say that
there's people out there fighting every
day for their lives
so i i yes but it's been rough
it's not easy to live in a wheelchair
it's not easy
especially in california it's very
difficult
to be handicapped and ada accessible
that's why i need to walk
are you cancer-free today yes you are oh
absolutely i was cancer-free
after three rounds of chemotherapy three
and i ended up doing ten how tough is
this whole stretch been for you because
even after overcoming
being in in your staycation prison you
overcome that and then this happens how
tough how how demoralizing is that
it's demoralizing but then you know i
went back i did a season eight of a
television show
and uh i sat on my butt and taught
and i did it pretty well we had a pretty
good
run and people just don't realize they
see you in makeup
and your hair done and they think oh
she's doing great they don't see what
happens behind closed doors
and that is where it gets tough that's
worked it's really tough do you have
24-hour help
no i can't afford that's all out of
pocket now
so how are you surviving alone
just you know it's a good day when you
can
bend over and get your pants on
but how hard is that to be sick and
alone
it's rough it's rough i have to save my
tears for the pillow
i want to ask you lori lachlan just
dealt with going to prison her husband
is still there what would you say though
having been there and come out what is
th what is it like
on the other side i met some of the most
intelligent
kind caring wonderful women
that i will ever meet people gave me the
shoes
off their feet not oh here's my shoes
shoes that they had to save money to buy
they had to order them it took months
for them to come in
i get there here you wear my size take
these
i mean there's women that i made
millions of dollars for
help them and they wouldn't give me the
t-shirt let alone the shoes off their
feet
so uh there's so many women there
that should not be there they took the
fall for some guy
or their boss uh somebody fled the
country so they got them instead
so uh i think it's crazy i think
you know me being there for eight months
had i not
been uh released on march 26th
had i stayed one more month i would have
died
i would have died in prison the health
care is so bad and that's the doctor
there in prison who took me off of my
thyroid medication
and my uh diabetes medication cold
turkey
all my medication january february
march boom cancer that has to do with
your thyroid
hmm interesting there is no way this is
not what you pictured yeah these years
no no i i have so many
wonderful things to do that i am so
proud of and so excited about
and then you know you need help going to
the ladies room
you need help taking a shower you're
afraid to do it by yourself what if you
fall
how are you going to be okay how are you
going to fix this
i i you tell me am i coming to your
house to live
where are you living now and how is it i
live in a hotel
you live in a hotel i live in a hotel so
that i can
call the front desk and send someone up
send a bellman up to help me
so they send a bellman up to help you do
all the things you need to do some
sometimes yes sometimes i'll you know
hire a young girl or maybe a a pt
student to come it's sad
i've been trying to get back to florida
to my house and my life there
since march 13th and
because of uh my doctors recommending me
that i don't travel that i don't fly
until i get the vaccine until we know
that it's working safely
i've been quarantined here alone you
know in a hotel
and because of covid it must be scary
every time someone comes in to help you
very scary very scary that's why
sometimes i just
hang out in you know my night gown all
day and do my work
and do my computer stuff and edit
and do those types of things because i
don't want anyone in the room
i had tried to use home healthcare for a
while
and uh it was so sketchy with who was
coming and what time and what day i was
like forget this
we're also seeing all across the country
where people are alone and they are
struggling with this but until you're
sitting in that chair
you don't understand how lonely it is to
you well
i'm an only child my parents are
deceased
i was never married and i don't have
children
so it's lonely
who's there for you my friends yeah
friends my doctors yes
but uh good friends loyal friends
none of those mothers from a tv show i
was just gonna have those
none of those maybe a couple here and
there
jojo and her family have been wonderful
have they
yes how proud are you of joe jones very
proud
i'm very proud what do you what do you
what do you think of what jojo has done
i i don't know if she's just a marketing
genius and we don't know this yet
uh i'm proud of her i'm proud of
everything that she does she's shooting
movie right now in canada
uh so she has all these things lined up
you know
she's she's great and it's great energy
to be around for me
it's it's uplifting and it's fun and
it's positive
and it's exciting and i like that you
know i've been to their home many many
times
uh you know they're they're there to
talk to they're there to call
you know and uh jojo calls me and texts
me with
every exciting new thing that she has
coming up so it's good to be involved
to be you know not forgotten
oh well we used you we we're famous now
we don't need you anymore
it's more of uh continue the journey
together
oh that's beautiful um was jojo how hard
was it for jojo to hide something like
this
but i never had fallen in love before
um but i always believed that like my
person was just gonna be my person
and if that person happened to be a boy
great and if that person happened to be
a girl great
i don't think she hides anything really
i think
maybe she just didn't know i have a lot
of students
that uh struggle with their sexuality i
will be honest mainly
guys that dance for me throughout the
years uh some have come to me and said
you know without you
i would have committed suicide to hear
that as a teacher
is shocking and and also
very loving and kind that i knew that i
did that for that child
and a lot of the guys struggle with that
and i
you know teach them to be very masculine
on stage and when they're performing
and what you do in your private life is
your business but uh
jojo really didn't have a private life
her life is
you know for the whole world to know
about every single thing that she's
doing with social media now everybody
knows what we're doing and what we're up
to every moment
and we tell them we share it so for her
to make that
statement and to share that and that's
what she wanted to do
i'm proud that she had the guts to do it
and uh she has a great environment and
her family and everybody you know hey
i'm single and sometimes guys are jerks
so good for her
and that's what i said i said you know
what jojo that's more hot young guys out
there for me
it's good that's good do you have plans
to return to tv
do you have i would like to return to tv
behind the scenes
and uh then there's been talks of me
coming back
and doing a show with the students
no moms but with the the dancers
themselves the teenagers
now that they're 16 17 18 19 20
we'll go at it each other they don't
need mom anymore
there is hope is what you're telling me
i hope
and i dream and i'm creative and i love
the creative process
i love the costuming and the music and
the choreography i love that part of it
all
and i think there's still a niche for me
but who knows
[Music]